[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[ROCK MUSIC PLAYING]
[GASPING, CRYING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[CROWD CHEERING]
[MAN AND WOMAN SPEAKING ON
TELEPHONE]
[DIAL TONE]
[END PLAYBACK]
RAHUL GAIROLA: Should we
being with some context
or do folks have questions?
I reckon there are probably
a bunch of questions.
AUDIENCE: Have things gotten
worse in the three years
since you've made this film?
I mean, this is pretty
terrifying stuff.
SAAD KHAN: The
only answer to that
would be, I'm here
now after three years.
But I do work in Pakistan.
I made that film
three years ago.
It was played at almost
50 film festivals.
And last year I shot this film--
you just saw the trailer--
and just like the
first film it was very,
like, gonzo, very--
you know, really
had to do it like hiding from
the authorities, I should say.
But yeah.
I mean, this one
was more dangerous
because we had to go to
villages and towns of Pakistan.
So yeah.
We just had like a three-person
crew and that is what we did.
The first one was-- it
was shot in two weekends,
but we spent like a month
and a half with the community
because it's really hard
to get into that community.
So there was a whole lot of
time researching with them,
and there's a lot
of handycam footage
which also ended
up into the film.
So yeah.
I mean, the film
was never played.
The first film that you
saw-- the film that you saw
was not played in Pakistan
for two, two and a half years.
And last year in November
we played it at our own film
festival that we did, and
it's for sexual minorities
in Pakistan.
It's funny because we don't
even have a film festival.
We had one film festival
called the Kara Film
Festival, which was canceled
because they didn't have money.
So in November we started
this film festival
for transgender and sexual
minorities in Pakistan.
That's where we played the
film, in Islamabad and Lahore.
So that was the first time
it was played in Pakistan.
RAHUL GAIROLA: And I think
one of the interesting things
about-- because I remember, I
believe I was at the premiere.
Wasn't it the United
States premiere in Seattle?
SAAD KHAN: Yes.
No.
Actually, no.
Frameline was the premiere.
Frameline, San Francisco.
RAHUL GAIROLA: But one thing
that you folks might not
be aware of is,
despite-- because I
remember hearing from Saad
on how difficult it was.
You almost had to
sneak around, right?
Because there are even
goons and spies and so on.
But this is even in
light of the fact
that since 2012 Pakistan is one
of the first countries in South
Asia to actually have
a law that recognizes
the so-called third sex.
This didn't happen
in India until 2014.
And right now Thailand in
this year is considering this.
But this really,
in a sense, when
we think about
queer identity or we
think about being
progressive in the ways
that we think about
gender, sexuality-- I
mean, here in this
country it's blowing up
because Hillary just announced
her intent to run, right?
And we think that
that's, you know--
the leaders of the free
world or the so-called West
are so innovative and
progressive with gender,
and actually these
kinds of things
have been a part of
South Asian culture,
iconography, and even
legally since 2012.
We don't even have,
in the United States,
a third sex or a so-called
"third gender" recognized.
SAAD KHAN: So its third
gender law, which means now
we have three options
on our identity card.
We have the male, the female,
and a third gender option.
So anyone who's transgender
or, as we call it,
khawaja sara, which
is an umbrella term,
and you put all of gender
and sexual minorities in it
so they can opt for that.
But no one really opts
for it because then they
can't travel to the
UAE and they can't
go to Saudi Arabia
for the pilgrimage.
And also you don't have that
option on your passport.
So, I mean, people
are saying it's
a step towards identifying
transgender rights,
but no one's really
opting for it.
RAHUL GAIROLA: And
something else-- yeah.
Thanks for the context.
And something else
that may interest
you folks in terms of thinking
about what you've just seen,
and surely when you go and
see "Showgirls," and also
in the context of other
queer or gay or lesbian,
LGBTQ visual texts that
you might have seen--
I'm sure everyone's seen
"Brokeback Mountain"
and other more popular
sort of American texts--
but one thing to note, if you
saw at the end, the writing
at the end said that Kami was
arrested under section 377.
And it's important to
know, this is actually
a pan-British colony section,
so when the British colonized
a lot of the countries
in the world--
as you may or may
not have known,
the presence in South Asia
was for over two centuries--
they instituted the
British penal code
377 which criminalizes any
sexual acts against nature
or any sexual acts that
articulate offenses
against nature.
This is even just same sex.
It can even be
queer sex, or sodomy
between heterosexual couples.
But what you saw
there, that's also
the same law that is--
there's a huge civil rights
movement right now in India
right now to repeal that.
So it's also interesting to
me how his work-- I mean,
both the films, because the
new one as well-- is really
challenging not just the
conventions of gender
and sexuality but also how those
conventions have been inherited
and instituted in
the legal code that
was inherited by the
former colonizers,
the former oppressors.
Which I find really interesting.
Because when we
think about the ways
that queer phobia,
sexism, misogyny, and also
Islamophobia-- I have to bring
that up because, you know,
we're in the US.
And our country tends
to-- certain people
from certain places often get
demonized in certain ways.
But it's ironic that
even in the wake of all
that we see these kinds
of representations.
And for me that makes it
really important to question
how liberal really are
Western conceptions of gender,
sexuality?
Especially when these laws,
section 377-- that is British
instituted.
And that's the
actual history of it.
SAAD KHAN: So yeah.
India was trying
to get rid of it.
And they did get rid of it,
but they reinstated that.
But in Pakistan in
the '80s-- so we
have the same law, the
anti-homosexuality law.
But the penalties--
like, after the '80s
there was a dictator,
Zia-ul-Haq--
the penalties are now Islamic.
So the penalties
are based on Sharia.
So it's the same law
bequeathed from the British Raj
or from Great Britain,
and it's the same law
but the penalties now
are based on Sharia.
That is the difference
in Pakistan,
which means that
you can get, like,
a certain number of
lashes if you're gay.
Never really happens,
but that's the law.
Let's talk about
if you guys have
any questions about the-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: What are the issues
about safety of your subjects?
SAAD KHAN: Definitely.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SAAD KHAN: So--
AUDIENCE: Were there issues of--
RAHUL GAIROLA: There
are mics on the sides
if folks wanted to
speak into them.
SAAD KHAN: So he
asked if there were
any issues about the
safety of the subjects.
For "Hide and
Seek," the subjects
traveled with us to film
festivals in Copenhagen,
Bangkok, and in Australia.
That was definitely
like the main concern,
and that's why we didn't
show the film in Pakistan.
And also it was just
shown in film festivals.
We didn't give any
big interviews.
This is a question which is
very relevant to my new film,
because the trailer
was online for six days
because we had to get funding
for our post-production.
And it was on
Indiegogo and it was
just like picked up
by Pakistani media
and also like
international media.
And they started
writing about it.
And that led to threats to the
girls and us, and in six days
we have to take it off.
So we're still dealing
with the second film.
We don't know how
we're going to do it.
I don't-- we're still
thinking about it.
But the first film, you
know, it's been three years.
Kami was arrested twice.
But that was because
he was-- I mean
he was coming from
the screening,
and to be honest he was
arrested because the police said
he looked too flamboyant, like
he looked like too effeminate
on the airport and that's
why he was arrested.
Yeah, but he was out
in like three nights.
[? Waseem ?], on the other hand,
we never got in touch with him.
Because as you could see,
he was raped by his uncle.
He uses the word rape,
but that's like-- yeah.
It just means sex in Urdu.
He doesn't-- that is
the word that he uses.
And the guy was
praying at the back
when I took him to the rooftop,
from the room to the rooftop.
We only had three or
four hours with him.
And from the room to the
rooftop, and he was over there,
and the film starts and he's
like, my uncle's watching me.
And I'm like, what is he--
why is he watching us?
And he's like, he's afraid I'm
going to tell you the truth.
So that was the uncle
who had the kid who
was also in the film.
And when he figured it out, he
had to-- him and his father,
they pushed us out of the house.
And we tried to get
in touch with him,
and always his father
used to pick up
or his uncles used to pick up.
This year, at my
brother's wedding--
because he was a
wedding entertainer,
at my brother's wedding, he
was a wedding entertainer.
And I saw him after,
like, three years.
And I told him about
the film, because he
was the only one who didn't
know what happened to the film.
So I told him about the film.
He was really happy.
And he was telling
me that he was
going to go to Dubai to be
a wedding entertainer there.
[? Jenny ?], on the
other hand, in the film
she's really depressed
because she was not
allowed by her college
to fully transition,
and was obviously
dealing with issues
with her religious
identity, and also she
comes from a tribal family in
[INAUDIBLE] so she was dealing
with a lot of issues and
obviously she was not
allowed to fully transition.
That is a problem
she's dealing with.
But last year she came to
the screening in Pakistan,
in Islamabad.
And she was-- that
was the first time
she saw the film in public.
And she is happy.
She's fully transitioned.
She lives as a woman
in Islamabad now.
So things have changed
in three years.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to know
about Kami's boyfriend-- what
happened to him, and
is he outwardly gay?
Is he publicly gay in
Pakistan where he workds?
SAAD KHAN: Yeah, Kami's--
Kami's-- Kami's simply--
I was telling him I was
listening to Kami again--
AUDIENCE: Kami's boyfriend.
SAAD KHAN: Yeah.
I was just telling him
that Kami himself is like--
RAHUL GAIROLA: I'm
not Kami's boyfriend.
SAAD KHAN: No.
But I was telling him,
Kami's simply love.
Like he's great.
He's so brave, and
so is his boyfriend.
He's from [INAUDIBLE],
lives in Karachi.
Yes, he's openly gay in a way
that his family doesn't know.
But yeah, he works as
an editor in Karachi.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SAAD KHAN: Yeah.
Yeah.
He wanted to be there.
We actually recorded a long
interview with him as well,
but it didn't make
it to the cut.
But yeah, he was in the film.
AUDIENCE: I really
enjoyed the film.
Two questions-- how did you come
to select the four individuals
that you did?
What was the rationale behind
selecting those four people?
And my second question is,
what was your overall objective
with making a film like this?
What were you trying to achieve?
SAAD KHAN: If I really
get into the details,
it was three years ago.
I was studying at
Boston University
and I wrote a short story, and
it had a transgender character
in it.
I tried to get funding for
that film, that short film,
and obviously I couldn't
get funding for it.
I got back home, put it
up online, got in touch
with the producer of this film.
He wanted to produce that.
And I told him, like--
he was Danish Pakistani,
but really hadn't been to
Pakistan in a long time.
So I told him that if he wants
to do my short film, which
deals with a few transgender
people, he needs to come down
and we should research.
So he came down to Lahore
and we started researching,
and got in touch
with one person,
and then it's like--
through that person
we got in touch with a
bunch of other people.
And we were--
initially we wanted
to have some-- talk to some
lesbian subjects, as well.
But they were obviously
at that time not willing.
There was also this guy who was
[INAUDIBLE] of a mosque, which
means he calls the prayer.
And he was like
[INAUDIBLE] cleric.
And he wanted to
give the interview,
but he didn't show
up the first time.
We scheduled it again, he
didn't show up the second time
as well.
So this happened with
like a bunch of people.
And as you can see, the film is
like we never really planned.
We never really knew what was
going to happen in those days
when we were shooting.
But it was all about the
community, the community
that we got into
and spent time with.
My producer actually spent
most of his time with them.
And that's how we got
in touch with them.
And we still are in touch with,
except [? Waseem ?], all three
of our characters.
And [? Neli ?] was the guest
of honor at the Copenhagen LGBT
pride parade two years ago, and
she was also at the premiere.
And yeah, so we really
believed to have our subjects
and they should also be a part
of the success of the film.
What was the motive.
I think it was
really because I'm
interested in groups on
the fringes of the society,
especially Pakistani society,
because I grew up in Lahore.
And growing up in a
very rundown area,
I used to peep
outside of my window
and there used to be
transgender groups who come
and perform, like,
every weekend.
They used to
perform in the '90s.
Now it's-- I mean, it doesn't
really happen that much.
And they used to
come and dance, and I
used to peep outside
of my window as a kid,
and I was like really fascinated
but also kind of afraid,
because I didn't know
what to make of them.
Because obviously
they're ostracized by us,
but then they were also very
much a part of me growing up.
I used to see them every week.
And there was this one
time I was peeping outside
of my window and these
two transgender women,
they were on the
curb of my house.
And they were-- one woman asked
the other woman, she's like,
your hair really good,
like what do you use?
She says, I use
the papaya shampoo.
And that was really
vivid in my head.
So you know I was like-- that
was the first time that they
were not doing that
all act of, you know,
flirting with the burly
men of the neighborhood
and dancing on child-- Like,
they were not putting an act.
It was just a
candid conversation
between two people.
So that really stuck in my head.
And that is same thing
with show girls, as well.
I grew up watching mujras.
My father used to watch it, and
then my brother used to watch.
Mujras are like the dance that
these girls do in theater.
There used to be this
dedicated cable channel which
used to show these dances.
And my father used to watch
it, and my brother also
used to watch it,
and eventually I
used to watch it as well because
we were, like, men of the house
and that is what they watch.
And they would watch
all of these mujras,
and at the end of the
entire dance sequence--
the girls dance
on-- these songs,
they're laden with
sexual innuendo,
and they do like
these suggested moves.
And it's very interesting.
And by the end of that
song, like for my father
and my uncles, they
were always the whores.
They were like oh, they're
the whores, you know.
And that was the kind
of-- I mean, for a kid,
it's very confusing.
I mean you're watching them.
You're consuming them.
You're going to watch them.
You're paying tickets
to watch them.
But by the end of it,
just to call them whores.
So that music itself and
also these women dancing,
they were all a part
of me growing up.
So I don't know, I
was at an interview
and they were asking
the same question,
like why are you interested
in these themes, groups
on the fringes of the society.
And I was like, because I grew
up-- kind of grew up with them.
So maybe it's like an
exploration of my childhood
through these films.
To be very honest, I just think
like they're passion projects.
They're about exploration
of my childhood.
That's exactly what it is.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So for
the show girls, I
know in like Thailand
they're also--
it's almost like a
tourist attraction, right?
Do you know if it's the same,
is it like culturally different
there?
It seems more open
or more prevalent?
Or is like religious
or cultural feelings
different with regard
to sexual minorities?
SAAD KHAN: So this is
like mass entertainment,
but not for the bourgeois or
like the creme de la creme.
This is like for someone
who works all day long
and they would go to
like a seedy theater
in these cities, a
few cities, and they
would watch these shows.
And that's just a way
for them to relax.
So even when people watch--
like for six days when
the trailer was
online, people were
like oh, well,
this thing happens,
or some people were shocked.
But then some people
were like oh, we've
seen this thing happen, but
it hasn't been shown this way.
They've always seen it in
like a kind of cable channel
which they would just skip.
So it's mostly for
the working class.
A guy who works all
day long and goes
to the theater to just
get his rocks off.
That is what it is.
So there are these--
the interesting part
is how the government
controls these dances,
or these theaters.
There's more control in the
cities, like the big cities.
But once you go away from it and
you are in villages and small
towns, the girls even take their
tops off and no one is there
to-- the government doesn't--
RAHUL GAIROLA: Surveil it.
SAAD KHAN: Yeah.
They don't do that.
But in big cities, they have to
wear kind of like body suits.
And they have to
do a dance in front
of five people from the
local police department
before the show, like
a week before the show.
So it's like an audition.
It's like-- what is the
equivalent of Britain's-- like
"America Got Talent," you
know, something like that.
So you have like five
six, girls queued up,
and there are five men
of the police department,
no woman in those like--
RAHUL GAIROLA: And they're
enjoying every moment of it.
SAAD KHAN: No, they're not.
AUDIENCE: Are they not?
SAAD KHAN: Because they're
not going to get it.
They really are there
to censor the dance.
So the girls, they just
really do a modest dance
in front of them.
But once the show is on,
they just really sex it up.
Because obviously people
are there to watch them,
and they have to make money.
So then the police department,
they would-- some girls
get banned, some girls
don't get banned.
It's just so interesting.
AUDIENCE: Yeah I
was just wondering
what the situation is around
female to male transgenders
in Pakistan.
SAAD KHAN: Yes.
That is a very
interesting question,
and actually I
know someone who's
working on a project--
I think they're
working with Vice on that.
But obviously they're-- I don't
know who said in the film that
transgender are the only--
transgender people are the only
visible sexual minority in
Pakistan because you see them
on the streets, dancing, and
they're begging at traffic
signals.
Kami said that, right?
But then comes the
G and B people.
But the L and female to
male transgender, they're
totally in hiding.
Or they're not in
the mainstream,
for obvious reasons.
They're not going
to be accepted.
The reason male to
female transgender people
are accepted is because of the
historical context of South
Asia, because in the Mogul era
the transgender people, male
to female transgender
people, were
the guardians of the harems.
And also in poetry, we have--
they're called khawaja saras.
It comes from this poet called
Khawaja [? Amir ?] [INAUDIBLE],
who used to write in Persian
and also in Hindustani,
like South Asian language.
And it comes-- he used to
talk about gender being fluid
and about being
transgender, and that's
where the respect comes in.
And also because
people would not
say anything bad
to the transgender
people on the street
because they're
afraid that they're going to
get a bad omen or, you know.
That is how they know.
But obviously like
female to male,
it's totally out
of the question.
RAHUL GAIROLA: And I
guess just to follow up
on your question really
briefly is what that--
and we had actually
discussed-- this came up
in Baltimore, at University
of Maryland in Baltimore
where we last saw each
other, but not University
of Washington back
when I first met you.
And one interesting thing about
your question and the answer
is that still indicates
a kind of sexism
around queer
sexuality, doesn't it.
That's the crazy part about it.
On the one hand, men performing
women or being eunuchs is OK.
But on the other hand, women
being lesbians or F to M
is totally transgressive, right.
It's the most
abject of the queer.
So it's very ironic how--
I mean but we-- we're
all here in New York City.
We all know how even
gay male identity
can be very misogynistic.
It can be sexist.
It can be racist right.
We're exposed to enough here
to realize those nuances.
But I find it really interesting
that in this context that Saad
explores in his work that
what seems to be liberatory
can also be oppressive.
AUDIENCE: Someone in the
movie said something about,
I'm not a gay who is
begging in the street,
but I go to the cafes.
So there's an inherent
classicism, as well?
SAAD KHAN: Yeah, and
that's very interesting.
[? Jenny ?] talks about it.
She calls herself a
modern transgender,
because she went to school.
And she doesn't want
to be classified
in the same category as the
traditional transgender people
who beg on the streets or who
dance on weddings and that's
how they make money.
But she calls-- she's
like, I'm different.
But then that also leads to
her being doubly marginalized
because A, she's marginalized
my her family, B,
the only place
she can get refuge
is the traditional
transgender community, which
is very strong.
So it has like a hierarchical
kind of family structure.
It's mostly transgender
people are ostracized
by their families,
and they end up
in these transgender
families which have--
they have this hierarchy.
There's a guru on the top,
and then there are proteges.
So [? Jenny ?] cannot
fall into that,
because she doesn't want
to be associated with it.
So she's doubly
marginalized in that way.
She doesn't have
support from anywhere.
Not from her family,
obviously, and then also
not from the traditional
transgender community.
And that also kind of led to
her being depressed in the film.
So yeah, there is-- Yeah.
So the answer is Yes.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I think you
did a really good job
of the fly-on-the-wall,
especially with [? Jenny ?].
You really let her talk
herself into the circle
and just prompted her with,
well you said you're depressed.
And you really let her do
that, which I find impressive.
I'm just wondering if there was
a point in time where you ever
found that difficult while
shooting to not impose
any kind of your own ideas
or your own thoughts on one
of their interviews
are on a situation.
SAAD KHAN: So when I shoot
and mostly I have the camera,
I really try-- it's
hard, because I
have to connect with the subject
as well but at the same time
kind of disconnect as
well so that I don't have
a breakdown like my producer.
But [? Jenny ?], at
that very moment,
like he couldn't shoot for
like three or four days.
And then I was with my friend
covering the other days.
Because it was too depressing
and it was just too deep.
And he is questioning her.
And I'm not really.
I just asked, like, a few
questions because I just
wanted to distance--
I knew I couldn't
deal with it at that
point, and he was there.
And that is what
teamwork is all about.
There are moments
when-- with show girls,
there are three subjects.
All three of them speak
different languages.
And I speak all those
three different languages.
And I was the only one who
had to connect with them.
It was kind of
hard in that film,
because I knew with
"Hide and Seek"
I had my producer backing me up.
But in "Showgirls,"
I had a producer
who was Canadian Pakistani,
and she could initially
barely speak Urdu, which
is my first language.
And she couldn't speak the rest
of the three regional languages
that the girls talked in.
And so it was actually hard for
me in "Showgirls of Pakistan"
because I'm very much
attached to my subject.
And to be honest, and
I'm just still processing
how to really like get it
out there, but also make sure
that the subjects are safe.
Because they're in like
villages and towns.
That is-- that's
not a safe spot.
Yeah.
RAHUL GAIROLA: One thing
that might interest you
and the rest of
you that are here
is there was actually, when
we did this event in Seattle--
and I hadn't even--
we hadn't met yet.
I turned up through a
queer South Asian group.
The president of the
queer South Asian group
refused to moderate
this talk, and that's
actually how I stepped in, I
don't know if you remember.
And one of the-- it
was really interesting,
because one might think, well
the queer South Asian groups,
here in New York
it's called Salga,
in Seattle it's called
Trikone-Northwest,
in DC, when we last saw each
other, it's called Khush DC.
And there was a faction, and
I, lo and behold, surprise,
surprise, it was the gay--
upper-class gay Indian males
of that group--
I'm one of those,
but I didn't agree with
what they were saying.
They had a major
problem, because they
felt like Saad was, why did you
have to one of the characters,
he's saying, oh well my
uncle used to rape me.
So you're projecting us
as, well, we only have sex
through rape, or
there's some sort
of sexual violence connected
to same-sex attraction.
That's-- the logic is
really flawed in that,
but I don't need
to get into that.
The second big complaint
was, at the end,
why did you have to have a
character, a subject, why
did you have to
represent or give
a voice to someone who regrets
having-- to being castrated.
Why?
Because you're proposing,
you're representing us
as rapists and eunuchs and
full of regret and all.
Remember when that--
in Seattle, and it
was this huge thing
that happened.
So--
SAAD KHAN: There was
also an announcement
before the screening where at
the Seattle South Asian Film
Festival, they
were like oh, we--
it's totally at your discretion
if you guys want to walk away.
Like it was crazy.
But then also my answer
to that was these
are personal stories
of these individuals.
And they're important.
And I also told you, you wanted
to talk about it at the Q&A
session, and I think we're
talking about it right
now because I didn't want
to talk about it that time,
because I was like if someone
has a problem with the film,
they should come and watch
it and ask me a question.
Then I can answer.
But I don't want to
take the spotlight away
from the personal stories
of these subjects who
put their lives at stake.
And you're watching
their stories,
and we're going to
talk about someone
who has a problem with
it who are not even
going to like show up in the
audience and talk about it.
But one thing that
we have to understand
that these are personal
stories of these individuals,
and they're very,
very important.
That is exactly--
I think that is
what I said to you,
as well, because I
didn't want to talk about it.
I was like if they had a
problem, they have a problem,
they should come and ask me.
RAHUL GAIROLA: I
actually came up to him
before and I said,
these are the two issues
and let's come up
with answers now.
Because I'm not-- I wasn't-- I
was having nothing doing with
oh sure, if you have a problem
with what you're about to see,
get up and walk out.
I'm teaching "The Bluest Eye,"
Toni Morrison, right now.
I had to do the whole
disclaimer to the class.
Oh, it's got rape and
incest and all this.
And then I said to them,
welcome to college.
It's rape, it's incest,
it's racism, it's violence,
it's prostitution.
Better us talk about it
in here in this safe space
than you go outside and have to
deal with it in your real life.
SAAD KHAN: But here's the thing.
These are-- you have to
understand the cultural nuances
and the cultural context.
When he says rape
well, that's kind
of-- he's not saying-- that
is the only way he can put it.
Like for him, sex is
not in his vocabulary,
so he uses the word rape.
Because that is how he's
learned it from Bollywood films.
And that's how he puts it.
It sounds like consensual--
yeah, consensual sex
between these two individuals.
And the guy happens
to be his uncle.
And that is what it was.
That was his own personal story.
And it's so important that
he's shared it with us,
and we have show it.
RAHUL GAIROLA:
Are we about done,
or does anyone have
any other questions?
AUDIENCE: [? Jenny ?]
spoke about counseling.
I think she was the
only one who spoke
about [INAUDIBLE] So
[? Neli, ?] she's somebody
who works for their rights.
Are there any
other organizations
that are working for counseling
for all these people,
because there are
a lot of issues
that they don't
speak about, right.
Besides talking
about [INAUDIBLE],
are there any groups--
SAAD KHAN: There
are a few groups,
and actually
[? Neli ?] is a part
of that group, that specific
big group, and also Kami.
So they belong to that group.
And they do provide counseling,
and they do HIV testing
and they do various things
for the LGBT community.
AUDIENCE: And that's completely
privately-funded thing--
the government--
SAAD KHAN: It's
internationally-funded,
and also-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: We also want
to know what [INAUDIBLE].
SAAD KHAN: Dude.
It was so interesting.
I think someone asked
a question to me
in one of those-- in one
of these Q&A sessions
that what was the thing
which was-- I mean all of it
was interesting
to me shooting it,
but this bar was in the basement
of a mosque and in [INAUDIBLE].
So that was the
most interesting.
AUDIENCE: It must be
quite underground.
I've lived there all my
life and had no idea--
SAAD KHAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: For an outskirt
of Lahore, it's quite--
SAAD KHAN: Yeah it's like,
it's-- yeah, central Lahore.
We only got like 20, 25
minutes, or maybe a little more
to shoot.
It was pitch black,
packed with people.
And that is the
only place we had
to put like artificial
fluorescent lights.
I don't think it's there.
I asked-- like whenever
I go back I ask.
I asked my producer as well
last year if it's there,
and he was like I
don't think it's there.
There was another
one in Jeff Heights,
you know Jeff Heights, right?
In Lahore.
AUDIENCE: It's kind of a
space that keeps moving,
like an underground space.
RAHUL GAIROLA: Like a rave.
SAAD KHAN: He--
RAHUL GAIROLA: A queer rave.
SAAD KHAN: Yeah,
the Jeff Heights one
was very-- they didn't give
us permission to shoot.
But this one did.
Yeah.
Yeah, you had a question.
AUDIENCE: So sexuality,
needless to say,
is subject to [INAUDIBLE].
And when you are talking
to sexual minorities
about their sexual practices
and their orientation,
there's always a
level of discomfort,
especially if you don't
have a rapport with them.
And this is something that I've
faced in my own research which
is on [INAUDIBLE].
And a lot of times I've
felt like my informants
were performing for me.
And when you add another
layer, which is a video camera,
in front of them, that just
complicates the situation
even more.
Did you at any point
during your filming
feel as though your [INAUDIBLE]?
SAAD KHAN: Not at
all, because we--
the key is to spend
time with your subjects.
And we still have a
relationship with-- I
just talked with our
subjects, and I just
talked about how I feel like I'm
in love with one of my subjects
from "Showgirls of
Pakistan" because I
have such intimate
relationships with them.
And that's why there
comes a point where
your subjects totally forget
that there's a camera there.
You've seen this
one scene in which
the [INAUDIBLE] or the proteges
and [? Neli ?], the guru
of the transgender clan,
they're on a mattress
and they're doing their thing.
And it's just--
it's very candid.
I mean at that point
I felt like-- that
was one of the moments
when I felt like a voyeur,
like I'm just there.
And the camera was running
for like 30, 40 minutes.
And they were just
doing their thing.
They just forget that
the camera is there.
Yeah.
I mean obviously
like if I go and if I
don't have a relationship
with my subject
and I just like put
a camera on, and also
one thing that I don't like
is putting so many lights on
and putting like a caller mic.
And that changes the entire
narrative right at that point,
because all of these things
affect the actual story.
So I mean I never have like
a caller mic or lights,
except that bar scene
I had to put it up.
Just to have like a
very personal connection
with my subject.
I'm sure a lot of
people do that.
But that is the only
way I can do it.
Obviously like shooting
with small cameras,
I can't move with like big
cameras and do these things.
Any-- done?
RAHUL GAIROLA: Well
thank you all for coming.
SAAD KHAN: Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]